architectural inspiration for excellent
design can be found
almost anywhere even in your own living
room but today i want to talk about some
of the best places
you can find architectural inspiration
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and architecture
today we're talking about the best
places to find architectural inspiration
so like always we're going to jump
around this house as much as possible
to keep you guys engaged the first place
i find my architectural inspiration
is instagram there are millions and
millions of different pages out there
that you can go out and follow
but i want to give you some of my top
and best architectural inspirations
that i always end up saving something on
instagram too the first page i find
really inspiring
is inspiring architect yes great pun
i know haha inspiring architect has an
enormous
feed that is continuously updated of
just architecture
you wouldn't find anywhere else it's
usually foreign architecture to me
it's not australian architecture but it
really inspires you
to push boundaries and go beyond the
limits the next page i follow
is a little bit more to home it's called
the local project
the local project features some of the
best houses in australia
and in new zealand and they truly are
some of the absolute
best they are all designed by architects
or for
architects even for their own personal
homes
so you know when an architect designs
their own personal home it's the best
thing i've
ever done because they put so much
thought and emphasis into detail on
those projects
the local page is phenomenal to follow
i'll run through the next couple pages
pretty quickly and throw them up on the
screen
so you can see what they do and some of
the amazing work they have so i also
follow amazing architecture
archi render tr vogue designs
my modern interior archi lovers and
a designer's mind out of that entire
list i think my modern interior and a
designer's mind
truly give you some of the best
inspiration from that list
so these two pages i definitely
recommend you follow to draw some
inspiration from i'll leave every one of
these links down in the description
below
so you can check them out whenever you
get a chance the next page i find my
inspiration from
is pinterest i know this is the most
generic
inspirational page you can find and
clients are going to come to you with
pinterest boards
that you're going to be sick of
pinterest but pinterest is a good
starting point it is one of those pages
that you can scroll endlessly and end up
finding the exact same thing you're
looking for
which is good i recommend making all
sorts of different pinterest boards for
all sorts of different designs
so for example i have boards for
residential design
in hampton style industrial style
modern post modern and all sorts of
different themes
i also do the same thing for commercial
design and then i break it down further
i have some pinterest boards just for
bathrooms and just for bathroom design
i have pinterest boards just for
kitchens just for laundries
just for small details pinterest boards
are great just to really remember and
refresh your mind on that
style and how you design a style and
what you like in that style
pinterest is not the be-all end-all it
doesn't have the best content
it doesn't have nearly anything up to
date that you're really looking for
but it does have enough to get you
started and that's all you really want
to remember with this point
the next source of inspiration is
linkedin linkedin is great because you
end up connecting with professionals
around you and in your area
so linkedin can genuinely give you some
up-and-coming projects
around your area that are doing
phenomenally well if you make the right
connections on linkedin
you can also end up getting a job from
linkedin so linkedin is one of the most
powerful inspirational sort resources
for architecture in 2021 one of the
things to keep in mind with linkedin is
linkedin is
very very public so whatever you do
whatever you showcase
whatever you'd like no matter whose page
you visit
is 100 transparent so if i go and click
on your linkedin page
you're going to be able to see that i've
clicked on it if i go and like something
you're going to be able to see that so
make sure that you don't like or comment
or view the wrong people's page
all right cool david linkedin what about
something a little bit less generic
well what about arc daily arc daily is a
phenomenal website and if you haven't
heard of it already
i'm pretty sure you have it has almost
every single project ever imaginable
that was any good
it has an overwhelming amount of
information on that website however so
just keep that in mind when you do go on
arc daily arc daily showcases some of
the best projects around the entire
world
so it doesn't matter if you're looking
for inspiration from germany greece
italy mexico or anywhere else that you
can think of there is more than likely a
project
from that country in arc daily one of
the best things about arc daily
as well is the simple fact that it gives
you all the floor plans all the sections
all the elevations
in great detail so you're not just
looking through some amazing photos and
going oh how did they actually make that
space work how did they make that room
work
you know very quickly how that architect
was thinking by simply looking at the
floor plans there aren't many resources
out there
that give you all the information in one
simple page so arc daily is by far
one of the best resources that you can
use to get architectural inspiration
from
moving further away from the cliches the
next point of inspiration is
architectural design magazines
if you work in an architectural firm
more than likely you have them
coming into your door every single week
if you don't work in an architectural
firm
and you're a member of the board or any
architectural association
most likely you're going to get a
magazine through them as well so one way
or another by being in the profession
those magazines end up at your door so
you're going to be able to grab some
inspiration from them
these magazines aren't exactly
architectural inspiration per se
in terms of elevations or floor plans
they're more so
inspiration for actual products so at
the end of the day
when your process is almost completed
and you're at the very last stage of
design
trying to compile that specification the
products you select are pivotal to how
that project is going to look
you can put together a 5 million home
but if you put project home
quality furnishings and fittings into it
it's not going to look that price so you
really want to make sure that you're up
to date with all the latest products
especially if you're working in that
luxury residential space
even if you're not even if you're
working in the budget space
you still have to know what budget
products are coming out so
it isn't all about finding inspiration
on architecture and colours and all that
it is as well about finding inspiration
about the best and newest products
and finally you can draw inspiration
from those around you
this one is a little bit more australia
based and more specifically western
australia based
i don't know about other cities and i
don't know about other states or
countries you can find some great
inspiration
on the council's website so for example
anybody that has submitted a development
application
with any council in western australia
can easily
look up their information you can go
onto any city's website find a
development application that's currently
in the process and out for public
comment and analyze their design
you can understand what's working in the
market what your competitors are doing
what anybody in that space is doing and
especially
you can find out what they're doing in
that exact same area
so it becomes a lot more targeted
understanding and a lot more targeted
inspiration you're not looking at things
that work in completely different
climates
you're looking at things that you know
are working
in that exact location that you're about
to start designing something for
yourself
the downside of this is the council
websites are flooded
with information on different projects
there is hundreds of thousands of
different projects that you can go into
and every single one of them is two
three four hundred five hundred
megabytes
every time you download them so you can
click on one project
wait five minutes for it to download and
it can be not relevant at all they give
you some really basic titles
like suburban commercial area they don't
exactly tell you what it is if it's
apartments if it's
townhouses if it's restaurants cafes or
anything
until you go inside that document
package you have no idea
but it does genuinely just give you a
lot of endless information
on any type of drawing that you're
looking for finally there's
one last resource that i recommend for
getting architectural inspiration
it is definitely left wing but it has
been in the media a little bit so it's
probably more so known to you now than
ever before
and that is reddit reddit has just an
endless supply of architectural
inspiration
there are a number of subreddits that
you can draw inspiration from
from interior design to exterior design
to architectural modeling and 3d
modelling for example some of the best
subreddits that i follow
for just ridiculous ideas are the simple
ones
r forward slash architecture r forward
slash
architect r forward slash 3ds max we
also have some more ridiculous ones that
just push the boundaries of
architectural design
like architecture porn and just design
in general
sometimes you can find the best
inspiration from product design and not
just architecture anyway that's all for
me today guys thank you so much for
watching i hope you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below this video
still forms one of my 28 videos in
28 days it would usually be i'll see you
next monday but in this case i'll see
you tomorrow